you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is the game
between bent Larsen playing on the white
end and Boris Spassky this was from the
USSR versus the rest of the world match
of 1970 Spassky at the time was world
champion and well let's see how the
world champ handled 1 b3 I think you'll
find this chess miniature to be
aesthetically pleasing the unorthodox
Danish Grandmaster is the guy behind
this very start to the game noted as
Larsen's attack
Spassky replying with e5 Bishop b2 9c 6
and move 3 c4 is not so common nowadays
III is more common more flexible keeping
open the option of Bishop to b5 now
that's c4 is in we can say that blacks
queen Knight feels a little bit more
secure King Knights are now out black
grab some space and continues to develop
Knight takes Knight and black makes an
exception to the rule of taking towards
towards the center here D takes on c6
black is really looking for or to build
on his lead in development and yes black
already has just 6 moves in a lead in
development only 3 moves out before
connecting rips now how did we get to
this point well that King Knight took
three steps to take a knight that only
took one continuing III there's some
attention on e4 by both sides Bishop e2
and queenside castle so Queen side
castles does two things in just this one
turn King safety rook activity that's
nice and certainly something to consider
when you have either a an open D file or
half open D file to work with black is
now working with a half open file
continuing we have f4 a better idea is
to start launching some pawns
or attempting to at least launch some
pawns towards the enemy king Larson goes
with that form instead taking out the e5
square taking the e5 square under his
control black should not capture on f3
on Poussin because of queen takes bishop
width check important details otherwise
maybe black could capture on e2 so okay
what do we do here just ten moves in and
yeah we're not long out from this game
just being over so what does Spassky
stir up what's the plan here well follow
up Knight to g4 is adding some pressure
to e3 and opening the Queen's eyes to
the h4 square
following up white takes out this option
of Queen to h4 and what would you do in
this position if you'd like to this will
just be the first of two pop quizzes in
this game what would you do in this
position is black feel free to pause the
video okay if you're tempted to capture
on this e3 square it's not a bad idea
you could go in for excuse me Knight
takes computer is a fan of this but this
is not as decisive as the following idea
spassky's idea namely - let's throw your
H pawn towards the h4 square
this is a super serious threat of h4 and
activating what what is h4 really doing
it's looking to activate the one piece
that isn't doing anything every one of
black's pieces is doing something except
for the rook on h8 but soon the rook on
h8 will be brought to life
by way of h4 and then I capture how does
white deal with this h3 in the reply
here it's just amazing
Spassky just ignores the threat on the
night after h3 he says you know what I
want the H file to open up and I will
get that
h4 okay pawn takes Knight is the
follow-up and now pawn takes pawn this
prawn you cannot put a value on this guy
he is now passed he is just two steps
away there is tension between the rooks
there is a lag in development for Team
white what are these guys doing nothing
the game move rook to g1 and doing
something else such as taking on each
one and then taking here that's going to
be painful because of check and that's a
killer pond making three already
computer suggests Queen D three that's
when you know you're having a tough day
so what does bent Larsen do here he
plays rook to g1 and the second of two
pop quizzes right now what would you do
there are many good moves in this
position but what was the move that
Spassky played here it's a really
beautiful move if he'd like to go ahead
pause the video what would you do what
did Spassky do
okay spassky's star movemove 14
RUP to h1
was that on anyone's radar yeah we're
just giving away a rook for what reason
well let's see the game follows with
rook takes rook G to this pawn is just
continuing to march and with great
effect now
punch thrown at the rook and now the
queen is ready to sweep into h4 width
check this is so serious that light sees
it best to play rook to f1 putting the
rook on a square the where it can be
captured doing otherwise playing - let's
say g1 allows the Queen to sweep in and
after King to d1 - now go all the way
down to h1 what's this rook doing
there's not a connection between the
rooks here and this is game over this
isn't a case even where you could say
you know what I'll give the material
back because you're going to get mated
so instead of playing look - g1 we have
rook to f1 in the game for the follow up
Queen h4 check King to d1 if you block
with the rook black simply promotes so
King to d1 and after pawn takes rook
promoting to a queen Larsson threw in
the towel and for a good reason
this is already a mate in 3 what to do
here after Bishop takes Queen we would
have Bishop takes pawn check if the
bishop blocks game over and if the King
tries to run that will also result in
game over what an end just a 17 mover
and a crazy H pawn that simply went on a
rampage and what
was the reason for this well another
case of one side it's a another instance
here where one side has a great lead in
development and put that to use black
was way ahead development wise and these
guys just never even got off the back
rank anyhow as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this chest miniature in
the comment section below
hope you're having a great day and I'll
catch you in the next video that's all
for now take care bye
you